bring back energy Independence Keystone  XL pipeline stop creating limits for the  permits already out there allow our men  and women who are out there drilling  responsibly with carbon capture  technology that I've helped develop that  fundraise for in my career I've had a  very extensive role in in gas and oil in  this country and I can tell you we cause  far less harm to the environment than  the occasional accident accidents happen  yes that's why they're accidents in  every industry accidents happen a banker  can accidentally round up a cash  register and add a zero and that changes  everything the whole yeah  um this is the problem with lying once  you start habitually lying you have to  keep lying to support the lies